the West Norfolk Community of Schnatter
shim is like most British towns and
villages a War Memorial at its Hart's
bears the name of local men killed in
the conflict there are 45 of them
the lettering was polished to mark the
centenary of the start of the war but
their individual stories had long been
erased from public memory I looked at
that and thought so we actually really
remember these people a hundred years on
we made a commitment at the beginning of
the project to strive to visit each
grave of of each gentleman and we've
managed it seen the number of burials
and their ages
[Music]
let's remember before God and commented
show people this year representatives
from Stettin have travelled to the final
resting place of every villager who died
on active service
we felt that actually going the extra
mile in this hundredth anniversary and
literally going and standing over those
graves and saying to those men in their
families we know exactly who you are we
know what you did and we're still
thinking of you poppies and wreaths of
West Norfolk lavender were left at each
grave along with a letter from a local
child snowshoe is a large village now
and you definitely would not recognize
it some of those personal stories are
heartbreaking families that lost more
than one child a lady who lost her
husband and her brother this project has
helped us to remember these gentlemen as
individuals known and loved and
remembered by us as a community the
study shown 45 span the full duration of
the Great War James Walker was killed in
August 1914 just a few days after the
first British soldiers arrived in France
Herbert Snell died in a German prisoner
of war camp a month after the Armistice
John and Charlotte graver lost three of
their sons
Harry George and Bertie Ernest day
pictured in this 1907 school photo lied
about his age and joined the army when
he was just 16 even though to his older
brothers had already been killed he died
two years later a hundred years old and
the class of 2018 have played their part
in bringing history to life thank you
very much for having me here today
I want to talk to you about what we have
been doing at the British Legion coming
up to centenary of the First World War
which this plays a great part in and
also then to listen to you and to hear
what you've been doing with your
particular project pupils have adopted a
soldier - right - some of them direct
descendants of the 14th
who died Nell Mitchell's ancestors
Sidney made it home from the front
despite a hand grenade exploding in his
face but he succumbed to his injuries
three weeks after the war ended thank
you again for saving our country I love
it here you're sincerely now Mitchell
we've brought our men and boys alive
to our children now because when people
of my age pass on we will have lost that
connection and I felt it very important
but the children now realize gosh they
were they were kids like us
[Music]
while many snyder men went to war the
war came to Snetterton in January 1915 a
German Zeppelin dropped a bomb adjacent
to the village Church leaving a huge
crater which is still there today
stained-glass windows were blown at the
intended target was the royal residence
of Sandringham just over a mile away
inside the church the same names as on
the town's war memorial among them
Charles Lincoln killed just five months
after enlisting in the army his page on
the newly created memorial website shows
his mother and sister visiting his grave
in France in 1920 now their descendants
are getting to know him I had some old
family photos my father told me a little
about him but my father was only seven
when he died I've been thinking over the
last few days what made him decide at
the age of 33 in 1917 to enlist and I
don't know the answer to it I guess he
probably saw lots of his friends and
relatives who were killed and he felt he
ought to do something and join up their
next of kin were presented with a bronze
plaque by the government three-quarters
of a million British and Irish military
personnel were killed harold meek was
the only one of the 45 who died at sea
his transport ship torpedoed by a u-boat
off the coast of Egypt his brother Percy
survived the war but he'd suffered
severe shell shock as a result of the
constant bombardment in the trenches it
left him paralyzed his limbs rigid his
plight documented on film but after
treatment including the simple therapy
of weaving baskets he eventually made a
full recovery and returned to Norfolk
[Music]
thus narration 45 project has inspired
relatives to retrace the steps of some
of the fallen ether and mainly juicy
Railton and her family have come to
France where to great great great
uncle's are buried Charlie Mitchell
almost survived the war he was killed
six weeks before the Armistice his
battalion was caught in a machine gun
ambush early one morning well I hadn't
realized is looking down the line
they're all Royal Fusiliers she goes
down the line it's all the same day it's
a bit overwhelming really I think it's
taken so long to get here my dad spoke
about coming here when we were little
and he's no longer with us today yeah
yeah and just seen the number of burials
and their ages it feels like we knew him
a little bit and I think that makes it
really difficult and you can kind of
relate to him in terms of he was roughly
the same age as us when we got married
and I just feel that you know he'd have
had all those thoughts that we had about
storing a family and all that kind of
thing then it's just never able to do
Josie's daughter who she christened
poppy was chosen to take part in a Royal
British Legion photo call with the Prime
Minister
she and her brother Elliot have written
to their uncles we think he was very
birth but must have been scared we want
to you to know that we are proud of you
and we'll keep you in our memories we
will try to visit again love puppy and
Elliot's if Charlie was here right now
what would you what would you be saying
to Charlie why did you
to the joy join the army yeah and what
why did you not want to stay with your
family you know you will get killed so I
heard that too they feel really sad he
went to the on the old Duchy full really
sad little is left of the trenches which
scarred the landscape and where vast
numbers died and were swallowed up by
the bombed and fractured earth their
bodies never found a century later
remains are still being recovered their
losses were so great it was actually
said you'd have to have bulletproof
soldiers to take these positions we find
20 to 30 bodies a year and they can be
given a proper burial
the names of 72,000 missing men are
inscribed on the thick Val Memorial
among them five men from Snetterton
including 21 year old corporal Percy
woods and Captain William Brown who
twice survived gunshot wounds in
previous battles but who lost his life
at the age of 24
now that is William Brown there okay now
what makes William Browns story all the
more remarkable is that he died on the
4th of September 1916 and on exactly the
same day in exactly the same battle his
brother Edwin was also killed leading
another company or the Norfolk regiment
the final parts of the Railton family's
World War 1 journey took them across the
border into Belgium and into woodland
which became the final resting place for
their other great-great-great uncle
Augustus Gus Mitchell Charlie's younger
brother he drowns in a flooded bomb
crater so we're gonna put the lavender
down from Norfolk that's left us with a
lot of questions hasn't it you've asked
questions how can you be in the middle
of a wood and drown further research has
revealed that tragically a second
soldier drowned while trying to save Gus
and I just think being able to put the
story and the name and the place
together just makes it all a lot more
real and especially for the children
because they need that because otherwise
it's it's just it's just numbers isn't
it it's just numbers and words to them
it doesn't mean anything until you hear
and see you know
the grim details of their deaths brings
no comforts but in a way this has been a
resurrection long gone but no longer
forgotten there was pride in what they
did the fact that is a small village are
45 men won two distinguished Conduct
medals and MBA two military medals all
of them were heroes
the Sneden 45 were just teenagers and
young men they never got the chance to
grow old after the war their friends and
relatives raised the money to pay for
this memorial and now a century later in
the village they called home they do
remember them
[Music]